[MUSIC PLAYING]
NEIL DAVIDSON: Thanks
again for the invitation.
Yeah, the invitation, it came
through our communications
department back in April.
And obviously, it's a
time of intense debates
within and outside Google about
the military application of AI.
And since then, there've been
some significant developments--
obviously, from your side,
Google's AI principles,
but also at the international
level, which I'll touch on,
governments increasingly
recognizing the need
to retain human control
over weapons and decisions
of the use of force.
So it's a pleasure to be here.
I think it's actually
a critical time
for discussion on this issue.
Militaries are heavily
invested in development
of robotic and
digital technologies,
including the software
that underpins both
and, increasingly, of course,
AI and machine learning.
I think it's also critical
that technology developers
and the tech
industry are involved
in the conversations
that are going on,
both at national level
and international level.
Now, I want to be totally
clear at the outset.
I'm not going to solve
any of your personal
or collective ethical
dilemmas, and I would never
claim to or try to.
But what I can do is
explain a little bit
how the ICRC, the International
Committee of the Red Cross,
approaches the issues of
new technologies of warfare.
And so before I
get into that, I'm
actually just going to say a bit
more about the bigger picture.
So I'm going to actually talk
a bit more broadly than AI
and ethics.
I'm going to talk
about conflict.
I'm going to talk about
the role of the ICRC.
I'm going to talk
about new technologies.
And then I'll get
into the implications,
because I think it's important
to understand the bigger
picture.
So first of all, quickly, what
is the International Committee
of the Red Cross?
For those who
don't know, we're a
neutral, independent, and
impartial humanitarian
organization.
So we work to assist and protect
victims of armed conflict
and other situations of
violence around the world.
Victims-- by victims,
predominantly civilians,
but also combatants, fighters
who are injured or detained
in armed conflict.
So we're an international
organization.
So our status is an
international organization,
but we don't have any government
membership or participation.
So we're independent.
Our mandate comes from
the Geneva Conventions.
International humanitarian
law, the rules of war
are essentially the
basis for all our work,
and I'll get a bit
more into that later.
Quickly, this is where we work.
Wherever there's armed
conflict, you'll find us.
We're in about 87 countries,
over 14 and 1/2 thousand staff.
Predominately, like I
say, where there's armed
conflict, but also in
capitals around the world
for humanitarian diplomacy
and preventive work,
working with
governments and others.
There should be probably
a small red dot--
I don't know if I have
a red dot on here.
I bet I do--
somewhere out there
in Silicon Valley.
There's now someone
this year who's
working out of our
Washington office
to engage with tech
companies in Silicon Valley.
This is a funding slide, but
the point is not the funding.
It's just to illustrate where
our major field operations are.
So these are our 10 biggest
operations this year--
as you can see, where there
are the major conflicts taking
place or major
post-conflict countries.
Funding, that slide is--
it's disappeared.
But essentially, the largest
portion of that graph
is governments.
Government's our
predominant funding.
The second largest slice
is the European Commission,
but we're increasingly
looking to improve funding
from private donors.
So what do we do?
Just very briefly, one of
our major areas of work
is protection.
So we work to protect those
affected by armed conflict,
whether it's by collecting
information on how conflicts
are conducted and
raising concerns
that we have with the
authorities and those party
to the conflict.
It could be visiting detainees.
It could be helping to restore
family links between those
who've been separated
during the conflict.
So that's protection.
There's also assistance.
And this is both emergency
humanitarian assistance,
but also, I would say, more
long-term capacity-building
for essential services, whether
it's water and habitation,
whether it's medical care
and medical services,
or whether it's things
like risk awareness.
The picture on the
right is risk awareness
for the civilian
population about the risks
of unexploded munitions.
The other major aspect of
our work is prevention.
And this really is
about long-term dialogue
with weapon bearers, those
who carry weapons, militaries
and others; the political
or military authorities;
and civil society.
That's a long-term
work, like I say,
to promote and uphold
the rules of law--
the rules of war, sorry,
and to carry out
humanitarian diplomacy,
basically in support of
our humanitarian work.
The picture on the right
is taken from our desk
a few weeks ago in the Hague
at the meeting of the Chemical
Weapons Convention.
So rather than try and explain
to you the rules of war
in a rather roundabout
fashion, I'm
going to use this short video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[BIRDS CHIRPING]
- Since the beginning, humans
have resorted to violence
as a way to settle
disagreements.
Yet, through the ages,
people from around the world
have tried to limit
the brutality of war.
[GRUNTING]
[EXPLOSION]
It was this
humanitarian spirit that
led to the first Geneva
Convention of 1864
and to the birth of modern
international humanitarian law.
[CHATTER]
Setting the basic
limits on how wars
can be fought, these
universal laws of war
protect those not fighting--
[BABY LAUGHING]
--as well as those
no longer able to.
To do this, a
distinction must always
be made between who or
what may be attacked
and who or what must be
spared and protected.
Most importantly, civilians
can never be targeted.
To do so is a war crime.
[BOY MIMICKING CAR SOUNDS]
- When they drove
into our village,
they shouted that they were
going to kill everyone.
[CAR DOOR OPENING]
[GASP]
[DOG BARKING]
[CAR DOOR CLOSING]
I was so scared.
I ran to hide in the bush.
[WOMAN SCREAMING]
I heard my mother screaming.
I thought I would
never see her again.
[GLASS SHATTERING]
- Every possible
care must be taken
to avoid harming civilians
or destroying things
essential for their survival.
[COW MOOING]
They have a right to
receive the help they need.
[JAIL DOOR OPENING]
[WATER DRIPPING]
- The conditions prisoners lived
in never used to bother me.
People like him the reason
my brother was dead.
[GRUNTING]
He was the enemy and
was nothing to me.
But then I realized that behind
bars, he was out of action
and no longer a threat
to me and my family.
- The laws of war prohibit
torture and other ill treatment
of detainees,
whatever their past.
[HEAVY BREATHING]
They must be given
food and water,
and allowed to communicate
with loved ones.
[SCRIBBLING]
[BIRD CHIRPING]
This preserves their dignity
and keeps them alive.
[HEART MONITOR BEEPING]
Medical workers save
lives, sometimes
in the most
dangerous conditions.
[EXPLOSION]
[MACHINE GUN RATTLING IN
DISTANCE]
- Fighters from both sides were
wounded in a deadly battle.
We were taking them to
the nearest hospital.
At the checkpoint,
a soldier threatened
us to treat his men only.
We were running out of
time, and I was afraid
that now all of them
were going to die.
[WHISTLES]
- Medical workers must always
be allowed to do their job,
and the Red Cross or Red
Crescent must not be attacked.
The sick or wounded have a
right to be cared for regardless
of whose side they are on.
[HEART MONITOR BEEPING]
[HEART MONITOR BEEPING
INCREASES]
- Advances in weapons
technology have
meant that the rules of
war have also had to adapt.
Because some weapons
and methods of warfare
don't distinguish between
fighters and civilians,
limits on their use
have been agreed.
[SHOUTING]
[EXPLOSION]
In the future,
wars may be fought
with fully autonomous robots.
But will such robots
ever have the ability
to distinguish between a
military target and someone who
must never be attacked?
No matter how sophisticated
weapons become,
it is essential that they are
in line with the rules of war.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
International humanitarian
law is all about
making choices that preserve
a minimum of human dignity
in times of war and make sure
that living together again
is possible once the last
bullet has been shot.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
NEIL DAVIDSON: So yeah,
it's all about limits,
international humanitarian
law, the rules of war.
So it doesn't say anything
about whether or not
a war starts, whether it ends.
It's about the
conduct, essentially.
And it aims to limit
the consequences.
As mentioned in
the video, weapons
have particular
consequences, and the ICRC
has worked on weapons
issues for over 150 years.
Our two core, I
guess, raison d'etre
in that area, our
core areas of work,
are to look at the
humanitarian consequences, what
we see in armed conflict, and,
interlinked, their compliance
with the rules of war.
And that includes considering
whether new rules might
be needed, as, in the past,
we've called for new rules
on chemical weapons,
banning them;
banning blinding laser
weapons; banning landmines;
banning cluster munitions.
Rules to regulate the arms
trade-- even last year,
over 120 governments agreed a
treaty to ban nuclear weapons.
And all of this, our
contribution to this
is based on either
the real or perceived
potential humanitarian
consequences.
In today's conflicts,
this is really
what kills most civilians.
It's heavy explosive
weapons in towns and cities,
and it's arms trade
transferring weapons
to those who aren't using them
in compliance with the law.
So this is something we're
also working on, of course.
But we also try to
look ahead and look
at how new technologies
are changing conflict
to look at what
the consequences,
in humanitarian terms,
might be, and to look
at what the legal
issues might be,
look at the compatibility
with existing law.
This is a meeting we
held a few weeks ago
on the humanitarian
consequences of cyber weapons,
looking at potential
risks for health care,
for essential civilian services,
and even the internet core
structure.
Now, I would say our focus
over the last 15 years
has been predominantly, as you
would expect, on increasingly
autonomous robotic systems,
on cyber weapons and warfare,
and now increasingly on the
software that underpins both.
For us, I should say,
we're not anti-technology.
It should be clear we're
not anti-technology.
So it can be that
military technology, even
in weapon systems, can help
with compliance with the rules.
So a precision-guided bomb that
uses a laser or a GPS signal
to precisely land on
a legitimate target
can offer better compliance
with the rules and the necessity
to distinguish between
civilians that can't be targeted
and legitimate military targets.
But that technology,
in itself, is not
inherently good for civilians.
Because if that
bomb is precisely
on a hospital or
precisely on your house,
then it doesn't matter that
that technology is precise.
It's also the way it's used.
So this is obvious, really,
but it's sometimes lost,
and it's an important point.
You have to look at the weapons
technology and also the way
it's used.
Now, this slide is in
South Lebanon, 2007.
And it shows an
orchard contaminated
with cluster munitions.
Now, cluster munitions have
been around for a long time
before they were
prohibited in 2008--
designed for things like
destroying a military runway,
loads of munitions
spread all over.
But that's not how
they're always used.
If they're deployed
around villages
where people are
living and working,
and if they land in
trees, then, in this case,
they hang down like
Christmas decorations.
As you can see, they have
a little tether on them.
And when someone comes
into that orchard,
they'll take your
arm off or kill you.
So the point is is
that you may claim
the reliability,
the effectiveness,
the safety of a
certain technology,
but it can't be
an abstract claim.
It has to be in the real world
in the context in which it's
used.
And that's something
we keep in mind
as we look at new technologies.
So of course, everyone
has in their mind
the idea of what an
autonomous weapon is.
My favorite nightmare, if I can
put it that way, at the moment
is from "Black Mirror,"
the episode "Metalhead."
I don't know if you've seen it.
I recommend it.
And maybe we'll get there.
I hope not, but maybe we will.
But the fact is autonomous
weapons already exist,
albeit a limited form.
And they don't look
anything like "Black Mirror"
or the Terminator.
The way the ICRC defines
them, an autonomous weapon,
is one that can select
and attack targets
without human intervention.
So it's the machine, based
on its sensors and then
its programming, that is
triggered by its environments
and self-initiates an attack.
So it's a clear distinction
between a remote-controlled
or a directly
human-controlled weapon.
But critically, it's not to
do with the sophistication
of the technology.
It doesn't matter if it's
got quite simple programming
or very advanced AI.
It's the lack of human
involvement in its triggering.
So I would say, if there was
one thing to think about when
I think about
autonomous weapons,
the first thing to think
about is unpredictability.
So by definition,
a robot, a machine
triggered by its environment
in a complex environment,
you have some level
of unpredictability
about when it's
going to fire, what
it's going to fire against, and
where it's going to fire, even.
And that depends a bit
the nature of the system,
but there's already
inherent unpredictability.
And I think that's important
to remember as we move on
through this discussion.
So today, what do we have?
This is a report from Stockholm
International Peace Research
Institute from last year.
Most autonomous weapons today,
they're quite constrained.
They mostly attack objects.
They're mostly designed
to attack objects.
And in fact, the vast majority
of air defense systems,
there are--
and I'll get to it in a minute--
some which have some
degree of autonomy
that search for targets
over a wide area there.
And there are some
anti-personnel systems
which have a degree of
autonomy in targeting,
although they don't quite
fit the definition of being
autonomous yet.
I would say it's important
to say that, like I said,
they're constrained.
Most of them target objects.
They're mostly
used in areas where
there aren't many civilians.
They're mostly
constrained in time
that they operate autonomously.
They're mostly
constrained in space
that they operate autonomously.
And critically, they're
mostly human-supervised.
Often, the human can
intervene and deactivate
even before the weapon system
carries out its attack.
So air defense systems, like
I mentioned, on ships but also
on military
installations on land,
they detect incoming
missiles, rockets.
Even some of these systems
that detect incoming rockets,
they have, at the moment, the
ability for a human soldier
to verify.
The machine says
a rocket's coming.
It's very simple.
This is not advanced AI.
This is trajectory and speed.
If it fits in the
trajectory and speed,
if it's coming to you within
this speed, then it fires.
So they check it
if they have time.
And they do have time, even
for an incoming rocket.
The missiles, they don't.
It's going too fast.
And that's one of the drivers
for autonomy in general,
is speed, from a
military perspective.
Loitering munitions,
most of these
are remote-controlled so far,
all different shapes and sizes.
But some of them are
autonomous already.
There's one which
searches for radars
and can search for up to
nine hours over hundreds
of kilometers for
a radar system.
It uses a very simple
technical signature,
electromagnetic
signature of a radar.
But you don't know
where it's going to land
over the next nine hours.
You don't know when, actually.
You don't even know
what it's going to hit
or what's next to that radar.
It illustrates the
issues with autonomy.
This is the only type of
system, as far as I'm aware,
that's deployed that is
directed specifically at humans.
Obviously, you can have humans
inside objects like aircraft,
but specifically at
humans, targeting.
You find these in a handful
of countries at borders,
at perimeters.
Now, so far, as far
as is understood,
these things can identify
human targets automatically.
They use human shapes,
heat signatures.
Again, I don't think it's
particularly sophisticated.
But then they send a signal back
to the human operator who then
decides whether it can fire.
But, of course,
you don't even have
to change the software
for that to be autonomous.
And actually, the
manufacturers already
say this could be
fully autonomous.
The users, so far, doesn't
put it in that mode
or decides to have it
set up differently.
So the point is this
is a current issue.
This is not a far-future issue.
That's been around
for at least 10 years.
The other thing to remember
about autonomy and weapons
is that it's not about specific
categories of killer robots.
It's a function.
It's a function that could be
applied to any weapon system.
And that's really
important to remember
when you're thinking
about the implications,
but also you're
thinking about how
to address the implications.
Militaries-- and
naturally for them--
they're investing heavily
in robotic systems, armed
and unarmed, air, land, and
sea of all different shapes
and sizes.
This is a capture from a video
explainer we did with Vox Media
in the US.
There's an infinite
range of the types
of systems that could emerge.
It could be remote-controlled.
It could be autonomous.
It's a function.
Obviously, as
everyone's well aware,
you can buy one of these type
of small drones in your local
[INAUDIBLE] or electrical
shop, [INAUDIBLE] being--
I don't know if you have
[INAUDIBLE] in Zurich.
Probably not.
What's your local
electrical shop in Zurich?
AUDIENCE: MediaMarkt.
NEIL DAVIDSON: MediaMarkt,
we have that in Geneva too.
So yes, I was at a conference,
and the company well this
was saying, well,
we could use this.
We could put some grams
of explosive on it.
It could be sent off to
kill people autonomously.
I mean, that aside, there's
already a lot of investment
in small drones and, of
course, in swarms of drones.
And there's a
question about where
the human role will be in that.
In swarms, for example,
there's a massive incentive
for autonomy, because how do
you control 500 small drones
at the same time?
Remote-control of small
drones are already
being used by non-state armed
groups in Syria, Iraq, Ukraine.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it
was on the newspaper,
ISIS uses swarm of drones
against the Russians.
And Russia did not have
defense [INAUDIBLE]..
NEIL DAVIDSON: Yeah, so
it's a serious question.
I mean, the question is,
for all of these systems,
what's the human role?
To what degree would there
be autonomy in the targeting?
And that's what
ICRC is focused on.
Yes, flying,
navigating, driving--
OK, fine.
But what's the really
important point?
The important point
is the targeting.
And that's what's important from
a legal perspective and also
an ethical perspective.
Now, I would never come here
to lecture you about software.
You'll know far more
about it than me.
But just to say that obviously,
the central component
of these future systems
is the software.
It is where that
software will either
be used to directly
initiate a weapon,
making it an autonomous
weapon system.
Or it may just be used as
a decision aid, a decision
support system
for humans who may
make, then, certain decisions.
I think there are different
issues raised by those.
I think they're more acute with
the one that directly triggers
a weapon, but there
are also concerns
where these systems are being
used to inform human decisions.
It's not theoretical.
And as you're well aware,
there's heavy military interest
around different parts of the
world in military application
of AI and, of course, for a
wide range of different purposes
and decisions and so on.
One of them is
targeting, what's known
in the military as automatic
target recognition.
And this is just an example--
it could have been pulled
from anywhere-- about efforts
to harness advances in
AI machine learning,
in image recognition,
in facial recognition,
in behavior
recognition, in pattern
recognition for targeting.
Like I say, it could be
directly to trigger a weapon,
or as a decision
support aid for humans.
It could be to identify
objects, people, patterns.
It could be even
to predict, as I'm
sure you could tell
me better than I
could in terms of software
capability nowadays.
So there's increasing talk,
in a conflict situation,
about algorithmic warfare.
And I think that's
a fair description.
So the important
point I want to make
is that the big picture is
this is all about decisions.
It's about decisions on
the use of force, decisions
to kill, injure, and destroy.
It's about the relationship
between humans and machines
in those decisions.
And yes, for us, the most
acute decisions to look at now
are decisions on
whether someone's killed
or whether a building
is destroyed.
But, of course, these could
have much wider implications
on other decisions in
armed conflict-- arrest
and detention, which type
of military operation
is carried out, even nuclear
posture, strategic decisions.
And there are
parallels, obviously,
with the rest of society,
discussions in other areas--
in transport, medicine, finance.
Criminal justice is perhaps
one of the best examples where
decisions affecting human lives
are already being influenced
by algorithmic,
data-driven systems,
but decisions which have
this kind of consequence.
So at ICRC, we've been
trying to get a handle on how
the technology is
developing in order
to inform our legal
and ethical assessment.
And like I say,
one of our concerns
in general about autonomy
is unpredictability.
And then we want to learn more
about AI and machine learning.
And one thing that's--
at least to us, and I'd really
be interested to discuss this
after-- is we see
a potential problem
of inherent unpredictability
with machine learning
algorithms, the lack of
transparency in how they
function, maybe a knowledge
of the input and the output
but not what happens in the
middle, questions of bias,
questions of safety, unknown
failures, and critically,
changing functioning over time.
Imagine a weapons system--
before you introduce a weapon
system in armed conflict,
you have to test it.
You have to decide whether, in
the circumstances you use it,
it's going to operate
within the law.
Well, if it changes its
functioning over time,
then you can forget it
because you can't assess that.
But there are these technical
questions that are really
pressing now, and urgent.
The ICRC's approach-- I mean,
so what to do about all of this?
Our approach is to say we
need to keep human control.
We need to keep human
control over weapons systems
and over decisions to use force.
This is a piece by our
president earlier this year
when governments were meeting
in Geneva to discuss autonomous
weapons.
And it's not an easy
question, actually,
what is the required
level of human control.
But it's a question that
needs to be answered
from a legal and
ethical perspective
because the loss of control
has really serious consequences
for civilians, for aid workers,
for fighters, for soldiers
as well.
An example, my
colleague in the field
mentions-- whenever I
talk about this issue,
he goes, yeah, sentry weapons,
how would I negotiate access
at a border or a checkpoint
with a sentry weapon?
So like I there are important
both legal and ethical
dimensions to this.
On the legal dimension, there's
been a serious misconception
over many years, this idea of
machines applying the law--
somehow, inanimate
objects with legal agency.
I don't know where it came from.
At least from
ICRC's perspective,
we've been crystal clear
that the rules of war,
they apply to humans.
They're applied by humans.
Machines may carry out
functions with different degrees
of automation, but
ultimately, human judgments
are required to comply
with those laws.
But then that means,
actually, the law
already limits the degree of
autonomy that is acceptable.
Because to explain this a bit
more, when human, soldiers,
fighters are
carrying out attacks,
they need to distinguish
between civilians and combatants
in that specific
circumstance, not in general--
there, now.
They need to make a
judgment of whether,
the attack they're
going to make,
the risk it causes to
civilians is proportionate.
So they may attack a
legitimate military target.
It creates risk for civilians.
Is that proportionate?
They need to make that judgment
now, then, not in general.
They also need to
take precautions.
So the situation
changed over time.
They need to cancel it.
They might need to stop it.
So the contextual,
they need to be there.
So this means there needs
to be human involvement
and it means limits on autonomy,
from a legal perspective.
But, of course, there's
also the ethical issue.
I mean, I know this
is something you've
been grappling with in
probably a different sense.
And again, it's across society.
It's the role of humans and
the relationship with machines
in decisions that
affect people's lives.
And, of course, these ones
are the most significant types
of decisions.
Many governments, civil
society organizations,
and much of the
public are adamant.
We cannot delegate decisions
to kill to machines.
What does that mean?
We need to work out
what that means.
For us, it means you need to
have sufficient human intent
to link the intention in a
specific context of an attack
to the consequences.
This is not a
generalized decision
to be made years in advance.
This is, at that point in
time, a specific human role
in that decision about
whether people are attacked,
buildings are destroyed.
There's also an issue
about human agency.
This is something-- the
ICRC's strategy at the moment
not only talks about human
control over decisions,
but human agency.
And I think this gets to this
idea about human intention.
And there's also the
question of human dignity.
What does it mean?
What does it require in terms
of that human involvement,
in those decisions, to
uphold human dignity?
And this is about really--
and people can fall
in different ways
on this in terms of their
ethical perspective.
Are you purely looking
at consequences,
or are you also
looking at the process?
Are you looking at just
if someone was killed,
or are you looking at how
they were killed and why?
This is an important
point about human dignity.
So what's our role in all this?
This is a picture from the first
meeting at the United Nations
in Geneva, 2014.
And I've had the pleasure--
I would say sometimes not so
pleasurable experience of being
there for every one of them.
In a multilateral sense,
especially in the current world
that we're living in,
there's been some progress,
but governments are
completely divided,
both on the scope of the problem
of autonomous weapons, and also
what to do about it.
So actually, the
majority of states
now want to see new
law that would either
have a requirement for
human control specified,
or that would specify
category of autonomous weapons
that you would prohibit.
As you might have gathered
from this presentation,
if you're going to have any
kind of regulatory approach,
it's going to have to be along
the human control element
because what I mentioned
about it being a function, not
a specific category.
Other governments, I would say,
want a kind of middle approach
where they want to agree
some politically binding, not
legally binding principles.
We'd like to have
human control, and we
think these are some
of the key elements.
Other governments, some major
military powers among them,
they said, no, we're
satisfied with existing rules.
We just need to ensure
they're implemented.
Now, that's on what
to do about it.
Now, I think one way
to say or to clarify
why some kind of international
limits are needed--
and ICRC has, for
several years, been
calling for international
limits to be agreed.
It hasn't said whether they
should be new law, politically
binding or otherwise.
But there needs
to be some limits.
And one of the
reasons is is when
you ask someone, or a
different government
or a different military or
a different person, what
is sufficient human
control, they give you
very different answers.
Someone would say, that
means remote control,
direct remote control in that
circumstance as, for example,
with many existing armed drones.
At the other end, someone would
say, at some point in time,
I programmed this
weapons system.
So therefore, in all
future circumstances,
it's kind of under my control.
Now, for me, that shows
there's a need to look actually
what that means in practice.
Like I say, we already
have some weapons systems
that have been used lawfully
and without some ethical concern
that aren't under
direct remote control.
So perhaps it's not at that end.
But then, I'm pretty doubtful
of it being at that end either.
So there needs to
be work to determine
what human control
means in practice,
and this is where we've
been pressing governments,
repeatedly and most recently
in November, to actually answer
this substantive question.
Because whatever
option you choose--
new law, politically
binding, whatever--
you need to work
out this question.
What does it mean?
Yes, all governments
have now agreed
on the importance of the human
element, human responsibility.
But what does it
mean in practice?
What's required for
compliance with the law?
acceptability with our values?
And this is the central question
that needs to be answered.
Now, what's your role
as technologists that's
working in the tech industry?
And far be it for me to suggest
what your role is, of course.
That's up to you.
But I would say that the
engagement of technologists
and technology developers
and the tech industry
is critical in
these discussions,
absolutely critical.
And it's not just on
the technical questions.
It's important on the
technical questions.
So if someone says to me, this
weapons system or this type
of technology, this
AI development,
that's going to save civilians.
That's going to protect lives.
That needs to be interrogated.
Someone needs to-- of course,
it's on the developer who
claims that to say, well--
to explain how that
technology works.
But there needs to also be
some critical assessment
of the technology, how it works,
not just the capabilities--
I know you're all problem
solvers with new technologies--
but also the limitations.
Actually, I'm more
interested in the limitations
than I am in the
capabilities, in some senses,
not, again, because
anti-technology,
but because it's important to
have a realistic assessment.
Because this is not
just theoretical.
It is already being
tested and used.
So we need to know what the
limits of the technology are.
It's not, well, in
20 years, we may
reach artificial
general intelligence.
It's more, we're using this
machine learning in this system
now.
What are the limits?
So I think it's been pretty
encouraging, I would say,
compared to other areas
that I've worked on,
particularly biotechnologies
and the risks
from biological weapons.
It's been actually quite
difficult to get the engagement
of biologists on
the dual-use/risks
of their technologies
and their research.
They say, well,
it's not relevant.
We're not developing
biological weapons.
It's true.
They're developing vaccines
or new medicines, whatever.
But there's a difference
in the tech industry,
I would say, at least from my
perspective as an outsider.
Technologists have been very
involved in the discussion.
There have been,
of course, things
like Google's AI principles.
There's been Microsoft's
call for a digital peace
in cyberspace.
There's been a
call for regulation
of facial recognition.
Someone mentioned to me earlier
that also, someone at Google
had been talking about concerns
about facial recognition.
There have also been open
letters by scientists,
by industry CEOs in robotics
and AI about autonomous weapons,
raising some issues
and concerns.
So I would suggest respectfully
that it's important
that you stay involved and
that you get more involved.
It could be to work
with organizations
like ourselves to better
understand the technologies.
It could be to work with NGOs.
It could be more at a company
level or an industry level
in terms of deciding how
technologies are applied
and looking at the
risks that they raise,
bringing the expertise
that you bring.
Like I said, I've been at the
last five years of discussions
at the UN in Geneva, and it's
predominately governments
and NGOs.
There's not many technologists.
There's not many tech companies.
And I think this
is an area where
there could be more
involvement and it could
be really quite beneficial.
So with that, I would say, thank
you very much for listening,
and I'll be pleased to carry
on the discussion with you
in the time you have available.
[APPLAUSE]